(gentle music)
- Would you like to have some tea with me?
(gentle music continues)
- Yes, I would love to have
some tea with you (laughs).
- So we have some options here.
I'll let you pick first.
- I'm a big mint tea girl.
- Oh, are you, okay?
- Yes.
- I've been eyeing this one,
the vanilla chia.
- Oh, I've had that,
it's good, yes.
- Is it good?
Okay, all right, let
me pour the tea first.
(gentle music continues)
- What kind of videos do you normally do?
- Yeah, so my favorite or I
guess my most popular series
is this one I do where I
have people share a secret
and I'm filming the back of their head,
so you don't see them.
- Rad.
- And yeah, so maybe we could start there.
Do you have like a little
secret you'd like to share?
- Oh my, a secret.
- This it's really hot, so be careful.
I didn't realize it would be this hot.
We might have to wait, like.
- (laughs) That's okay, I
actually really like when it's,
my secret is that maybe I
like to secretly be burned.
- I swear to God, me too.
- (laughs) Like my soup
has to be like scalding hot
or I can't eat it, my
tea, it can't be warm.
It has to be hot, so.
- Yeah, your name's Autumn.
Is there a reason your
parents gave you that name?
- I was born on the first day of fall.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah, my parents
didn't really have a name for me,
and I think I was nameless
for like a few hours actually.
- [Thoraya] Oh shoot.
- And then they like
were looking at the calendar
and they saw it was the first day of fall.
- That's such a cool story.
- And they chose Autumn.
And my last name's Ivy.
- Oh, Autumn Ivy.
- So Autumn Ivy like
is perfect together (laughs), yeah.
This is like my favorite
place in San Diego.
- Oh, Kate Sessions.
- [Autumn] Mm-hmm.
- This is just my second time here.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh, this is like a maybe
every other weekend vibe for me.
- Wow.
- I'll just come and hang out.
- See, I wish I was like that.
I don't do, every time I have free time,
I just like sit on my couch.
- It's easy to do that, I
do that too sometimes too.
But like I, especially just
'cause I'm new to the area,
I really try to like get out
and do something that's
like meaningful (laughs).
- Have you made friends
doing stuff like that or?
- It's funny, we were
just discussing this.
I've been here for a year
and I really, she's like my only friend.
- Oh really?
- Yeah (laughs).
- If you have a good friend,
you know, that's all you need.
- Right.
- It doesn't matter.
- Yeah, but like recently I've been trying
to like get out and be more social.
It's just easy to like
be by yourself sometimes.
- Yeah.
- But yes.
- Let me look through my
list of questions here.
- Yeah.
- I usually ask really deep
and personal questions.
- That's fine, I love that.
That's what we just did for
the past two hours (laughs).
- And you said you were
talking about going,
doing things outside
your comfort zone too.
- Yes.
- And then that's
when I came up to you.
- Yes.
- That's perfect, is there
anyone you need to forgive?
- (sighs) You're starting
right off the bat (laughs),
heavy hitters, right?
(gentle music continues)
(birds chirping)
- [Thoraya] Is there?
- Yeah.
- Are you willing to
share? You don't have to.
(gentle music continues)
(birds chirping)
(Autumn laughing)
Makes you a little nervous.
- Yeah, sorry, I don't
wanna get emotional.
- It's okay, no, it's fine,
I mean, if like it's a.
- I'm an emotional person,
I'll cry at anything.
We were just also discussing this.
I think that the biggest person
I need to forgive is myself.
- Okay.
- I think that I,
in the past few years,
have forgiven other people
so that I don't have to carry that weight.
And then, you know, I
still have a little bit
of forgiveness to give myself, but yeah,
that would be my person, I think.
- [Thoraya] Okay.
- Yeah, sorry, geez.
- Thanks for sharing that with me.
- Yeah, of course.
- So do you feel like you
have been forgiving yourself
or taking steps towards that, yeah?
- Yeah.
- And how are you doing that?
- Being gentle with myself.
- [Thoraya] Oh wow.
- Is definitely something that
I've like just been trying
to make a priority in my life.
I guess I do that in ways
like stopping and thinking
about when I'm in a loop in my head,
like you don't deserve this,
you don't deserve this.
Yeah, I do, I've done
this, I've done this,
I've worked hard for this
feeling or this opportunity
or even just this life in general.
- That saying to be gentle
with yourself, that's so sweet.
Like I'm gonna tell
myself that from now on.
Damn, we really did start off.
- (laughs) Yeah, I wasn't
expecting that at all.
- Okay, so next question
is maybe a little more
lighthearted hopefully.
- Okay (laughs).
- What is a song
that reminds you of someone you love?
- Aw, that's sweet.
(aircraft droning)
Okay, so my dad and I connect very,
we communicate through music.
- Okay.
- I was actually just telling her this
that he'll send me a song
and then I know exactly how he's feeling.
If you would look through our messages,
it's like Spotify, Spotify, Spotify.
- Like you don't even
write, that's so funny.
- We don't even have to write things.
But one that we send pretty frequently
would be "Woods" by Mac
Miller, it touches my soul.
Like it speaks to my soul, I love it.
The first line is, "Things like
this weren't meant to last."
So I think that you could
kind of take that any way.
Hi.
- Hi, you wanna
have tea us?
- Oh, you're cute.
- [Thoraya] We have all kinds of flavors/
- (laughs) Oh, do you
like your butt scratched?
- [Friend] Hi!
- Hey, pickle ball buddy.
- Yeah, how are you?
- Oh my God, good,
how are you (laughs), there's Tada.
Yeah, I'm having a tea
with the stranger today.
- Oh, that's so cool.
- It was nice seeing you.
- [Friend] I'll get
outta your shot (laughs).
- Bye (laughs), what are the chances?
That's funny, so I recently
started playing pickle ball.
(Thoraya laughing)
- (laughs) So anyway.
- So we play pickle ball with strangers
and she's one of 'em.
- She's one of them.
What are the chances?
- I know,
that's actually weird.
- The universe today
is like really weird,
I'm getting really weird energy today.
Not bad, just kinda out there.
- In a good, magical way, right?
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
- So you said something earlier, you said
that sometimes you feel like
you're not deserving of things,
and even on a large scale,
what's something that
you've been wanting to do
or what you've been wanting
but you've felt like you've
been undeserving of it?
Which I'm sure you are deserving of.
- Oh boy, I'm gonna start at the top.
- Okay.
- Large would probably
be like own a home (laughs).
- Okay.
- I think a lot of people
would probably feel like that.
- Right.
- I didn't ever think
that it would be so out of reach for me
to like own a home one day.
I don't know, like how hard do I have
to work like to deserve to own a home?
- [Thoraya] Yeah.
- You know,
like I work really hard
and I'm nowhere near it.
So that would probably
be at the top for me.
- When did you realize you
were not like everyone else?
(gentle music continues)
(aircraft droning)
- I think that what
would make me different
is that I'm very empathetic.
I call it my superpower
sometimes, I don't know.
- That's a good way to
be different I think.
- Yeah, I'd say.
- Do you think you were born that way
or do you think that was
like the way you were raised?
- I think it's a product
of my environment.
I've actually talked about this in therapy
and 'cause I didn't realize
it until somebody told me.
- You didn't realize that
you were super empathetic?
- No.
- Okay.
- I thought that I, well, I thought
that I was really good at reading people.
- [Thoraya] Oh.
- Which I would say that I am.
- [Thoraya] Yeah, yeah.
- But I actually realized
that it's like the product of my household
was to kind of guess
how people were feeling
so that I could react accordingly.
- Oh.
- So if somebody
was in a bad mood, I could tell
by the way that they were walking.
- Oh shoot.
- The steps
on the floor upstairs, oh, they're upset,
the way that the door closes,
they call it fortune telling
in therapy.
- [Thoraya] Oh really?
- That you're like fortune telling.
So it can be good, like
when you're connecting
with somebody, like I
know how you're feeling,
like I feel that for
you, that kind of thing,
but it can also be like harmful for you
because you're constantly trying to guess,
is this person upset, are they okay,
what can I do about it?
You just have to like sit
right in the middle of it
and like know when to
take yourself out of it
and be like okay, how am I feeling?
'Cause like that has nothing
to do with me, you know?
- Yeah, and have you been doing that?
- Yes, yes.
- Oh okay.
- Past few years, for sure.
- That's so crazy, so you
would be able to tell just
by like how someone was
walking at your house, like.
- Yeah.
- That is a superpower.
- (laughs) Well, I mean,
when that's all you know
is the sound of somebody's
footprint, or footprints,
footsteps coming in the door,
what kind of mood they're in,
it kinda just tells you more
about the household than it does you.
It's just like you like evolving
to like the environment.
So definitely a product of my environment.
I don't think I was born
like that, definitely.
Ooh, okay.
- You going?
- Yeah, what do you think
your purpose in life is?
- Well, it's the big one.
I really do think my purpose
was to like do what I'm doing now.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, meeting strangers,
sharing stories.
- Yeah.
- It's really incredible.
- Thank you.
- You would never,
I would've just kept sitting
up there and being like,
what are they doing down there
if you wouldn't have come up, so.
- That's crazy.
- Yeah, it's cool.
You're like making memories
for other people and yourself.
- I love that, when people say
that they'll remember this,
it's like so crazy 'cause like
obviously I'll remember it,
but like I always forget
that like other people
are experiencing it too, yeah.
- It's a shared experience, yeah.
- Why do you think we met?
- Oh.
(gentle music continues)
I think like this whole day
has been like meant to be,
honestly, I don't know why.
I think it was really cool to
be very introspective today
and think about things I haven't thought
about in a long time.
Also, like you're really cool
and I would totally hang out with you.
So, and I was just saying like,
I want to have like more friends here,
I don't get out enough.
So like maybe that was the
universe today being like,
hey, check like a few things off your box,
your list like today.
Because like everything
has been like in line
with everything we talked about
today, it's kind of crazy.
- I know, right?
Right off the bat too.
- Yeah.
- And it like honestly I couldn't
have picked a better first person
'cause I've been like
really struggling getting
into filming again.
And I'm so glad you're
like the first person.
- Oh, I'm glad I was too, it was fun.
- I actually have, wait up,
this has your name on it, that's weird.
- Wait, what?
- You wanna open it?
(paper rustling)
I dunno where that came from.
(Thoraya laughing)
(gentle music continues)
(birds chirping)
- Aw, what is it?
- You have to read the letter.
(gentle music continues)
(paper rustling)
(birds chirping)
(gentle music continues)
(laughs) Should we hug it out?
Oh, you're gonna make me
cry, stop, thank you so much.
Stop crying, I'm gonna cry too (laughs).
- I don't have words, thank you.
- So the letter says, "Hey, Autumn,
"hope you have as many trips
to Kate Sessions as possible
"and that you take many
well deserved relaxing days.
"The world also hopes you reach
your goal of owning a home.
"It may not be much, but here
is $200 towards your home.
"You're so deserving,
"thank you for sharing today."
- Thank you.
- That has to be your
first $200 for saving it.
- It's going straight
into savings (laughs),
I can tell you that.
- Any ending thoughts 'cause I
have two million subscribers?
So (laughs).
- [Autumn] Are you serious?
- [Thoraya] Anything you wanna tell them?
- Take risks.
(gentle music continues)
I don't know, take risks.
If I didn't do this today, I mean,
I wouldn't have developed this
connection with a stranger.
Yeah, love deeply, listen to others and.
- Be gentle with yourself.
- That's my favorite thing
that you've said today.
- Thank you so much.
- That's a good job, woo!
- Wow, like I love that.
- Actually, could I have you,
what was going on through
your head when you like this?
- When you gave me the letter?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I just thought it was another one
of like weird ass things
that have happened today.
That's like everything
is like in the universe,
like do do do do do do do.
I was like, wow, you
have my name on a letter?
That's crazy, wow.
(gentle music continues)